yeah I know welcome to this video this
is another part of this three minute
madness it's not that I'm wanted to do
this every day it's just I made some
technical changes today I adjusted
something and the microphone hoping to
improve the sound which I'm not sure
it's doing any good but I want to try it
out and the second more important thing
and this might lead to trouble is I'm
just bought a new mouse and I'm
replacing my old one which had problems
with the right mouse button enter in
general a little bit as well so
switching to a new mouse is always some
the horror off every night blitz player
at least they're on my end so I'm just
jumping right in with some games in the
three-minute pool I don't get a game and
as I mentioned when I kicked off this
series just just yesterday basically I
don't care so much about the results
here just want to have some quick fun
and I guess with the mouse I'm going to
have some issues anyway especially those
click finishes pre moving and so on you
really have to be yeah you have to be
completely adjusted to the to the mouse
I don't get it came there what's what's
what's up with a cc today it's really
slow ish I mean slower in terms of not
that the response or anything is slow i
don't get games rule usually this is by
far the server that gets your games the
quickest and i don't get one here what's
this yeah the general feedback on this
idea of having a sensor such a
light-hearted serious was was pretty
good so I'm going to make some of you
don't get 1a is that 13 something oh I
actually accidentally played Knight f3 I
didn't want to just out of routine I
went went with this but maybe I can get
something funky anyway
yeah don't you going to get this in
style of the the bird opening a form
maybe I can get something like laska
loses power he went f6 so he wanted to
remove my night down okay yeah he's at
79 that some finish I am pretty good
player played him lot over the years
it's the name until y ella solo probably
not exactly the correct pronunciation
but ok so I want to get rid of the night
down that looks pesky on e4 and I know
well III is a bit weak but he doesn't
get to this so quickly Queen you one not
quite sure where I'm going with that but
it seems okay and you have to be quick
and three minute you just cannot think
so long three minute is really I think
in terms of them the general attitude
it's closer ready to bullet then then to
25 minute I'm attacking you six asking
him how it's going to protect it it's
not easy actually King f7 it looks
really ridiculous so he had to give me
that now even Queen g3 does make some
sense but the issue is that it's still
not that that easy to play okay maybe I
have to show g4 actually that's a good
idea Bishop f8 looks almost forced here
no I didn't do that okay but f5 for
Bishop h5 looks good
I'm very really well here in this
industry with this somewhat somewhat
them exotic openings people really AM
have their their issues there I can take
care right for possible checkmates or
not cheeks their tix III th7 King f7 my
95 yeah that's that's made okay so he
went age six I can probably go Queen
edge for ticks there I am that looks
that looks okay just attacking age 64
queen age 70 Queen g7 matey cannot take
the bishop again
check check and Queen g8 green double
check and made black resign so what's
fun and I didn't have any time scramble
again started ok so now I'm going for
playing the actually promised aggressive
style Knight f3 it went I was just just
automatic move that I do not would be I
have to readjust their what is he doing
now thinking about this now Daniel Poole
that that's actually his name ok I down
the air prove it ok let's go for this
myth Maura it's the clients often again
here people have no heart there ok I
understand the idea I always also
declined the Smith more are quite often
all my mouth oops no I have to get
adjusted to that okay see I don't want
him to take on C 3 i'm not sure 95 is a
bit early but not interested interesting
come let's go like them okay yeah but if
i go back now I mean if he takes I don't
mind that so much maybe you can check
play you fine but other than that and
think it's so great okay wow he doesn't
i thought if he plays it sexy has to
take one c3 I mean now I'm just pressing
against the rickety six bond right this
release the true just a week porn I
think don't see any any particular
compensation Brooke ad one looks like
the normal next move
oops not against that one okay yeah I
understand the idea but you don't get
the night to d4 here probably that's um
it's a serious problem with this
approach Bishop on g7 and upon this
night is not it's not doing much plus is
really slow
yeah it's not make a big success on
earth at trading trading stuff is just
going to get me a good end game so let's
just straight down night stays bad there
on a six and check basically a pawn up
okay let's go see five he cannot even
take that but if he does I can pre move
this and I'm threatening to take on be
60 we did take see going for some count
to play there I don't see it here
probably okay so let's drop back first
and I have Queen d7 air that sets an
even bigger problem here then taking a
seven what is are you doing with your
pieces now there are 58 seconds that's
good if you have spent less than the
other guy has left is always good black
resign okay game started the long that's
probably really the IMO is it GM is a GM
right yellow every launch yeah poker
academy probably not not a chess player
anymore it more like a poker player okay
what do we get here starting with Knight
f6 and I can go for the bank oh I know
it's not really a Vecchia opening or
anything but it's a it's aggressive
enough for me ok actually meter wrong
order they're entering into the old main
line where a four is really problematic
for black okay
yeah they play it differently nowadays
and I am usually I mean I care don't
play the Bangko and hopefully but if I
do I really would have preferred to go
for the other line yes he's right of
course I cannot go to e5 here that's too
bad ok maybe I can at least provoke a
pawn move it might be weakening a bit
but I mean not seriously I'm I'm
perfectly aware that I didn't play that
well okay maybe just for Queen we
actually wants to use this ok let's try
to get this traded still have some Mouse
issues but it reads it's fairly ok no
now I have some counter play definitely
maybe maybe not enough but I have some
play ok do I want to place you for not
probably just this one yeah it's it's
it's interesting now he cannot move his
pawns really and and I'm pretty active
so that's not bad at all cannot play c4
though maybe just do full-scale invasion
here preventing any beer pong move or
whatnot ok night see for preventing
Jeff it's not easy for him to play this
and I'm very active 94 possibly take the
bishops III mated okay maybe I should
use this lever takes checks okay I have
a center p cheeks or wait I can take
with the porn actually it could be
interesting I can do this still it's
interesting i REM really active here I
know if he takes I have a double up on
there but it is damn active right how I
see how is it playing that's not easy
for white okay maybe you can take plane
i def to forget it's returning a pawn or
not now not not totally not not easily
maybe maybe i can put the night to e4
actually it's may be interesting
k still it's a question though here
brooke d 3 is coming maybe this for
night 494 a 494 look moves looks it will
check time going to be really annoying
here okay if he has to take my pawns
will will be strong okay it's rather
giving up the exchange that's probably
the right decision okay check sure it's
not easy at all to play nice check 86
and 95 is a problem or care to go here
and that wasn't really what I wanted I
played that really well at the end up
check not not before but near the end
check check check check check I came
very woman check checkmate ah not losing
his bad losing his bad this was just a
great position here that he allowed me
the Queen trade was pretty terrible but
I couldn't really put it away this is
just a great for black I didn't I didn't
didn't manage to win this Bishop g1 came
back I don't want to analyze much in
three minute it's um it's not very very
pointed to said this this idea okay
let's see next game
Chuck that's really different different
way of handling this mouse some more bit
different now for those wondering what I
got I got a logitech 50 2g 502 was
recommended to me by one of my students
matrons okay really feels okay to use
but did some it's still still tough if
you have used a mouse for two years on
an honor basically daily basis and then
it's somehow gained its external okay
let's get oops making not the king oh
it's really a bit different there okay
who is this here kiss shake untung shmoo
shmoo yeah okay okay this is not really
wacky but wacky enough for my taste
Beckett this type of I don't care about
the center opening I'm sure do you play
Knight f6 even here I don't know but
let's castle maybe you could have played
I think it probably could have played
that you find earlier okay may I can
keep the night down
yeah sometimes you can just let the
other guy take their on your form and
claim that uff compensation not sure
this is one of those positions let's
just take him jammer bishop is pretty
pretty bad maybe I should I should try
to suck up on with Bishop b5 somehow
okay let's do that you will not take he
will play Bishop before or something
here okay let's try to keep it for the
moment a porn I mean night that 1d seven
that's really a bad bad piece
too much choice i think i have to do
this the trade I mean go to be five
trying to invade Queen a voice is
something maybe you can check me simply
check and then try to promote the pawn
that that was definitely a possibility
ok maybe here i am setting up something
like a pin down I mean it's not a real
pin but it's annoying for him that I'm
and looking at the night all the time
and can has some kind of somehow improve
him Wow
I cannot play okay five really it's not
on okay what do you want to do here
check check sure I can just take this
right when I can I don't take I don't
see it I have g5 time morning I've I EST
si yes I'm King age three King age three
check I was thinking this but he has
King h3 this is this is a this is really
important otherwise I always have check
96 or other checks you can also take age
five this is the problem yeah I just add
what a shame not sure that it was so bad
at the end chicken I really have no way
out him
yeah oh there k lack resins not sure he
is so bad look it doesn't look so bad
here yesterday I have to play rook to
aid some some defense movement yeah I
relied on the check yet he has various
ways King h3 is also ok that was I've
got Queen D 1 no I have Queen D 1 i'm
just winning here no ha of course that
what's that is really stupid you know
I'm channeling easily here check check
time I winning now rook GA this winning
I've whatever have to continue huh ok me
gay man spawn whatever ok ok he's the
one with the funky opening now yeah this
a 6b five people always quote the Tony
maths was a scalp of game that Matt's
managed to beat cop off with that what
they all failed to say is that miles was
totally crushed and then kappa blundered
it was not due to the opening what you
took up of being surprised or so I don't
I don't think so he really didn't care
much what his opponent was doing ok I
was just playing quickly here see what
he's now doing to defend g7 what is he
doing and b5 also hang so not quite sure
why it took only five
Bishop f6 threatening loopy six now Jack
I'm going to take the pawn here and now
okay probably going back not sure all
the way on 32 maybe he i am the back
rank could be it could be an issue so
here for nazi for a white knight f4
might be might be a problem
it isn't even so easy it is that isn't
easy he still has activity I'm not well
developed ksh five then 23 if he trades
i don't believe really he does but ok
now i can try to get stuff I want yeah
that's it's really true I don't have
great squares but b7 is unprotected so i
can do that problem
rook e8 maybe still should be a good
move I mean those pins here are tricky
each one is unprotected my back rank
that looks a bit shaky but 95 is a
threat down some blood sure okay that's
that's possible check here don't want to
go into pin immediately if he moves the
night I can just take c5 actually 95 why
not 94-97 yeah I'm an exchange up at the
end so it's no reason not to check okay
so this is an exchange it's still a bit
of still have to be so you have to
convert it check
I could have taken actually time warning
probably played some stupid moves them I
mean I can't just take before maybe I
should actually ok this is maybe too
complicated for my own good but thought
this should work now Madge the pawn in
six might be five hmm it wasn't that
wasn't good check check no check wanted
to go somewhere else Oh charlie check
check I can take my rook there check all
my mouth check ah my mouse not a
possible I'm just I'm just too slow with
this thing I mean it's a deserved loss
probably anyway I mean ok I was
completely winning but screwing this
screwing this this end game up is just
embarrassing yeah not here ok but oh I'm
really slow with this mouse yet or still
I really have to have to get used to
that there's no reason why it should be
it shouldn't be slower or anything it's
just a matter of getting used to it
okay so one one more game to to finish
this session gain started okay so maybe
I can get some gambit out of e5 yep
something halfway serious I mean despite
I'm in this session it's meant to be a
bit a bit of fun but I don't play
completely rubbish openings like them
and the Latvian or something where
you're just giving away a pawn plus the
game I mean it's just like just
unplayable I think something like that
is a line okay if he takes it I thought
Queen jizz six maybe but i'm not sure if
i have enough compensation there yes
night f4 i am that's really really
problematic but okay I don't want to
trade Queens in this situation
94 if I get it played it's not it's
quite interesting but
hmm yeah but I do now wreck it probably
just taking unfortunately I'm lacking a
movie and some way check i can take the
I oddity that forces him to take with
the with a king look that looks really a
bit bit wrong why but i'm not i'm not
seeing yet how to punish that he has
really lots of material Bishop h3 is
interesting but i don't i don't think it
works this is this this yes
counter-attacks there if I sacrifice
everything okay just let's just do this
keep this poll now that should also be
quite okay
I still have a bishop age three ideas ok
so now I can thinking is not really
going to work
yeah I don't really see a good move
Quincy three of us may be quiet time
morning maybe quite good okay that's bad
news i have to give up this okay and
it's just take that pawn and see how he
continues night h5 maybe no check on the
aid
awkward that's an awkward move Queen d8
don't don't have any good reply to that
Wow and there's night h5 that's also
coming Queenie seven is good now
probably Joe Queen yourself okay well
plan okay sighs yeah it wasn't really
well well played here this session what
did I score that day to check that it
was really terrible it was for losses at
the end Wow and I love pretty good
positions ready okay anyway it was a
test session for this mouse and the
sound I'm not really sure ok I have to
adjust to the mouse definitely him and I
will ultimately but at the moment I
don't feel very comfortable um yeah I
hope the sound was an improvement i'm
absolutely not sure about that so please
send me some feedback there thanks for
watching